19:57 is asked to do some incidental  music for television call  [Music]  and I get this in Bill Cosby hot Lanta  him ever in the middle of the night  there's a tape recorders the type of  time in the studio's collecting them  together in one studio and working in  said I had to be put back next morning  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I love machines for a computer to be an  extension of the arm of the comparator  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  we can beat up any sound we can possibly  imagine  [Music]  [Music]  listen with your inner ear  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  thanks for watching don't forget to  subscribe and click the bail to receive  notifications for new videos see you  again soon